OK, let's go back to the phones at six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty.
A lot of folks interested in chatting.
Let's go to our caller from the six three
six area code.
Caller from six three six.
What's your name?
Where you calling from?
Hello, David.
This is Luke.
Hey, Luke.
So I have a pretty simple question.
So you see the video of George Floyd, and
that's really kind of seems to be what set
off these current Black Lives Matter protests
that we're having.
And I just wonder, like, why is it that this
is the thing that finally set it all off?
Do you think it was just four years of Trump
and tension building up?
Because we've known for a long time that the
black community has been experiencing all
these injustices and nothing's really set
it off yet to this extent anyway.
That's why it's a combination of things.
I think you had, number one, a population
that is as unemployed as it has been for a
long time because of the virus.
So you had a lot of people already sort of
aching to get involved in something that felt
good.
They weren't.
Most people weren't going to do the anti mask
protests because that's idiotic.
Most people understand what's going on with
the virus.
So you had an incident that was on video.
It was so egregious that even many people
on the right said, hey, this was wrong.
This like, I can eat even people on the right.
And, you know, I'm going to let you go because
there's some there's some kind of noise there.
I'll answer offline.
So you had people see the video of what happened
with George Floyd.
You had overwhelming agreement that it was
an injustice.
You did not initially see the officers arrested
people or more home than they've been for
a long time.
And so it was sort of like the perfect storm.
Then the president reacted in the worst possible
way by saying, oh, protests against police
brutality.
I encourage the governors to dominate the
protesters and I'm sending in the military.
And that exploded things even more.
So it was a perfect storm of sorts would be
my perspective.